le meilleur live bonjour nous sommes en
direct ce lundi midi pour vous faire
vivre le tirage au sort des huitièmes de
finale de Ligue des Champions il y aura
aussi un petit tirage de Ligue Europa
mais ça arrivera à 13h je suis avec
Cédric allier bonjour Cédric bonjour
Vincent Joyce sport au Figaro avec vous
on va décrypter ce tirage au sort ce qui
attend le PSG vous attendez du Figaro
vous n'hésitez pas bien sûr à poser vos
questions on y répond au mieux comme
d'habitude on voit déjà des gens qui
veulent un réel PSG c'est possible on va
analyser un peu déjà ce qui ce qui
pourrait arriver pour le PSG seul équipe
française dans malheureusement dans
cette Ligue des Champions bien
évidemment le tirage au sort ils disent
que ça dépend que ça démarre à midi ça
ne démarre jamais à midi évidemment
aussi on a pas les droits pour vous
diffuser les images mais c'est pas grave
on va quand même en parler on va quand
même le vivre avec vous Cédric c'est un
peu dommage effectivement mais il y aura
qu'une seule équipe française et en plus
de ça on est ils sont deuxième de groupe
ouais c'est ça c'était une phase de
groupe un petit peu décevante on va dire
aussi bien pour l'un que pour l'autre
bon pour Paris le fait d'être toujours
là en 8e de finale mais quand même pas
dramatique pour Marseille
malheureusement le le but à la dernière
seconde de Tottenham qui les élimine
enfin ils étaient pas encore qualifié
pour la Ligue des Champions pour les 8e
de finale mais ça les élimine de toute
compétition européenne c'est un drame
effectivement ils ne sont pas en Ligue
Europa et du coup le PSG se retrouve
deuxième après une phase de poules
plutôt correcte sauf qu'on Benfica bah
en fait et après c'est c'est la la
grande question de savoir Benfica fait
quand même un début de saison
extraordinaire il y a une qualité de jeu
donc c'est pas c'est deux
contre-performances entre guillemets à
l'échelle du Paris Saint-Germain ce
qu'on essaie ils sont censés au-dessus
de cette équipe là maintenant il faut
pas mes estimer cette équipe cette
équipe de du Benfica et bon on a en
Ligue des Champions ça pas été toujours
convaincant ça c'est certain et au
classement UEFA d'ailleurs deux clubs
portugais qui sont au premier dans les
premiers groupes Benfica et Porto oui
alors on va compenser avec la Ligue
Europa on a on a on a quatre encore
quatre clubs enfin trois clubs en Ligue
Europa et un en Ligue Europa conférence
donc pour l'instant il y a pas encore le
feu au lac au niveau du au niveau de
l'indice alors on verra à ce moment-là
alors sur le site de l'UEFA ils sont en
train de montrer les petits équipes déjà
qu'est-ce quel club vous a vraiment
surpris vous a vous a un peu étonné sur
cette phase de poules et qui est un peu
vous les attendez pas forcément et ils
se sont montré très très fort bon je
pense que je vais surprendre personne on
sites en Naples je pense que vraiment
cette équipe a été
ça termine quand même meilleur attaque
de la phase de groupe 20 buts
personnellement bon je vais avoir je
suis désolé j'ai du mal à dire le nom de
de je vais dire simplement que
Varaire le Géorgien là qui a été une
révélation incroyable que personne ne
connaissait il y a trois quatre mois bon
on y met on connaissait puisqu'il était
passé par par la Ligue 1 mais bon de le
voir à ce niveau là puis puis surtout ce
qu'il y a des tonnes en Ligue des
Champions c'est que finalement c'est pas
pas forcément ces joueurs là qui ont
brillé ils ont brillé avec le fils de
siméone avec Raspa Dory qu'on voit pas
trop en série a donc ils ont l'air
d'avoir une profondeur de banque qui est
assez étonnante donc et puis ils étaient
dans un groupe qui était pas pas si
simple que ça ils n'ont vraiment survolé
effectivement avec Liverpool qui qui
arrivent à battre et à l'inverse quel
club se qualifie mais vous a quand même
pas donné une super impression
ah bah je pense que dans le groupe de
Marseille on va dire que Tottenham
en tant que premier alors pourrait faire
figure d'adversaire idéal pour le PSG je
suis un peu moins sûr peut-être que
j'enverrai peut-être un autre que je
vous citerai après mais
Tottenham a fait une phase de groupe
très très compliqué à l'image d'un Harry
Kane qui qui est excellent Première
League et qui est en Ligue des Champions
est un peu transparent qu'il est selon
vous du coup le meilleur tirage de la
pour le PSG alors Tottenham ou une autre
équipe moi j'aurais tendance quand même
à citer Porto je pense que Porto et puis
bah Vous vous parliez un peu de l'indice
donc pourquoi pas pour essayer de
rééquilibrer un peu tout ça sortir
carrément une équipe une équipe
portugaise sachant que le PSG ne peut
pas jouer Benfica puisque c'était dans
le même groupe et tout puis Porto ils
sont deuxième donc de du championnat
portugais ils sont loin de Benfica ils
sont quand même à 8 points
ils sont sortis d'un groupe qui permet
pas de se dire oui son premier ils sont
impressionnants moi je pense que de la
bonne équipe sur l'état de forme du
moment Chelsea ferait aussi figure de
d'adversaire idéal maintenant ça c'est
toujours la problématique encore plus en
cette année de Coupe du Monde de se dire
que l'état de forme du mois de novembre
sera pas forcément l'état de forme de la
fin février et ça ça va être ça va être
une donnée à prendre en considération
surtout qu'il y a une petite Ligue des
gens une petite coupe du monde au milieu
quand même qui risque de changer de
chambouler un peu tout ah bah oui oui je
sais que
ayant beaucoup d'amis supporters
parisiens ils s'inquiète beaucoup de
cette coupe du monde parce qu'on sait
pas dans quel état reviendront mes
cinémas Mbappe jusqu'où ils iront
sachant qu'en plus vous allez de cas de
figure qui sont problématique à gérer
entre ceux qui vont aller très loin et
qui risque d'avoir
usé beaucoup d'énergie et puis ceux qui
risquent d'être éliminer très tôt qui
vont revenir avec une grosse déception à
gérer peut-être un contrecoup sur le
plan mental donc ça on a on l'a jamais
vécu encore donc on va voir c'est vrai
que la vérité d'aujourd'hui sera pas
forcément celle de février une deuxième
trêve internationale en plus au final
parce qu'il y a il y en a une habitude
en juin il y en a une nouvelle en
décembre en fait voilà et puis bah là
une longue donc voilà donc après mon
pronostic de coeur moi ce que j'espérais
c'est Naples Naples Naples pour le pour
le PSG c'est pas le tirage le plus
simple mais c'est une équipe c'est une
équipe qui joue au foot donc déjà qu'il
laisse qui va laisser des espaces on
sait que Paris aime ça voilà pour pour
le déplacement elle est à Naples c'est
juste extraordinaire en terme d'ambiance
et puis il faut quand même pas oublier
que cette équipe de justement on a dit
que c'est des jeunes joueurs et tout
ils ont été fabuleux jusqu'à présent
est-ce qu'ils vont pas connaître à
contre-cou un moment donné et ce qu'ils
vont pas être attrapés par leur
inexpérience je pense que pour le PSG je
dis pas que c'est l'équipe la plus
abordable loin de là mais
si je peux me permettre cette expression
ça de la gueule c'est moins un
épouvantail en gros les trois équipes à
éviter est-ce que c'est City unique et
le Real Madrid alors
sur sur Munich sur et certain il faut
quand même voir ce qu'ils font depuis le
début de la saison alors certes il y a
eu quelques petits ratés en Bundesliga
mais ils sont quand même impressionnants
ils sortent du fameux groupe de la mort
à 6 matchs victoires ça a été propre ils
ont ils ont pas remplacé les wandowski
donc ils ont pas de neuf ils ont des
buts absolument incroyable voilà il met
des et puis surtout c'est tout le monde
marque dans cette équipe vous avez Sané
monsieur
de partout donc ça c'est une équipe très
compliqué le Real de Madrid pour tout ce
que ça représente ça serait compliqué
City City je trouve que City au complet
c'est terrible là on est mal et tout
mais on voit que City allant n'est pas
là dès que rodrin n'est pas là au milieu
de terrain on sent qu'il y a quand même
des joueurs qui sont vraiment vraiment
essentiels on me direz il y en aura dans
toutes les équipes mais je trouve que
City dès qu'il décalant des roderies
sont plus là c'est plus tout à fait la
même et De Bruyne évidemment alors on va
pas leur souhaiter d'être blessé ou des
choses comme ça mais bon alors on aura
l'avantage de pouvoir se reposer pendant
tout le mois de décembre enfin novembre
décembre donc on verra avoir comment
avoir comme il revient Real Madrid
tenant du titre on s'en rappelle les 8e
dernier c'est pas mal c'était c'est
comme une équipe qui est toujours
compliquée à prendre et qui en plus
cette année joue quand même très bien
oui oui on sent qu'ils sont qu'ils
arrivent un peu mieux à gérer les
absences de Benzema
l'émergence de de Rodrigo et de Vinicius
enfin Vinicius on a déjà vu la saison
dernière Rodrigo aussi mais continue de
grandir et continue de progresser mais
l'ascension de Valverde au milieu de
terrain qui est énorme qui est peut-être
l'un des meilleurs joueurs pour moi l'un
des peut-être trois meilleurs joueurs
sur cette première moitié de saison ce
premier tiers de saison donc c'est une
équipe qui reste très compliquée mais si
Benzema n'est pas là
ça reste quand même jouable plus
probable justement un commentaire qui me
disait Sony qui voulait un petit une
petite revanche du 8e dernier bien sûr
on va ça c'est tous les supporters
parisiens l'ont encore en travers de la
gorge parce que parce qu'il y avait
clairement la place de passer quand on
voit qu'elle était le parcours du Real
derrière on peut mais bon avec des
signes Paris aurait déjà gagné 8 Ligue
des Champions effectivement qui nous dit
que le il préférait avoir le FC Porto
pour pour le PSG le FC Porto l'a dit le
supporter en plus à faire un groupe
était dans un groupe dont le deuxième
c'était quand même Bruges d'ailleurs les
vertus 3e et le favori la TECO Madrid
termine 4e ouais là ça fait presque je
veux pas dire classement inversé parce
que j'aurais pensé que dans ces cas-là
moi j'aurais dû finir premier puisque
ils sont pas passés loin
sur la dernière journée maintenant
l'Atletico de Madrid c'est plus trop ce
que c'est depuis le début de la saison
on voit qu'ils ont qu'ils ont du mal
défensivement c'est plus la même
solidité qu'avant offensivement
ils ont dû gérer un petit peu
bizarrement le cas Griezmann ça y est
maintenant ils peuvent le gagner
normalement voilà la ligne est
normalement ils ont beaucoup de bons
joueurs mais ils ont pas su gérer le
départ de Luis Suarez donc c'est pour ça
que Porto sort d'un groupe qui qui pour
moi est un peu similaire à celui de
Tottenham ou une chose comme ça où il y
avait quatre bonnes équipes mais bon pas
des pouvoirs taille alors que le Real
Madrid le Real Madrid sort quand même un
groupe avec l'Inter et le FC Barcelone
mais bon ça c'est voilà mais avec la
manière en plus et puis et puis mettre
un nombre de buts impressionnant ça joue
il y a l'expérience enfin il y a pour
moi le Bayern c'est c'est presque le
pire surtout que contrairement à ce que
je disais par rapport à City ou au Real
real le Bayern ont l'impression qu'il en
manque un ou deux joueurs ou deux ou
trois joueurs ça sera pas dramatique
parce que parce que même même un petit
le petit jaune le petit français Mathis
tel qui arrive à jouer qui qui a marqué
deux buts en Bundesliga donc il y a du
il y a du potentiel partout quoi donc il
aura d'ailleurs une bonne partie de la
première moitié de saison pour l'instant
ça s'est pas vu et effectivement alors
que le tirage au sort va commencer dans
quelques instants je l'ai sur mon écran
c'est pour ça que je regarde mon écran
en même temps on va essayer de faire
réussir le tirage au sort du premier
coup cette fois-ci aussi on est un petit
souci l'an dernier je crois on avait dû
le refaire 3 heures plus tard parce
qu'on était rendu compte qu'il y avait
un petit souci voilà là je pense que
quand même normalement c'est géré par
des professionnels donc
effectivement donc on va voir ce tirage
au sort alors en fait comment ça se
passe c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois on
peut rappeler un peu les règles de
comment ça se passait on va tirer une
équipe et on va exclure toutes les
autres parce que on peut pas jouer
contre une équipe de son pays ni un
deuxième de groupe c'est ça le deuxième
de son gros deuxième de son premier donc
ça ça peut enlever pas mal d'équipes
alors que le live 6 a été tiré en
premier donc on commence par les
2e de groupe live 6 donc là ici je ne
peux pas jouer contre le BM de Munich
qui est un club allemand ni contre le
Real Madrid Leipzig deuxième de groupe
avec Christopher nku qui est plutôt en
forme
que même que même excellent qui est qui
j'espère j'espère qu'à la Coupe du Monde
il aura la possibilité le temps de jeu
pour confirmer mais là pour l'instant il
marche sur l'eau je crois qu'il est il
doit être meilleur au deuxième meilleur
buteur de Bundesliga pour l'instant donc
hier soir
donc toujours et donc le premier la
première affiche la voilà c'est la ici
je contrôle Manchester City bon bah
c'est déjà ça de moins dans le dans le
pied de du Paris Saint-Germain c'est en
plus une équipe allemande qui du joue
qui va sans doute libérer des espaces
pour allande ça peut ça peut être sympa
ça peut être sympa ça peut être sympa
Manchester City quand même clairement
favori sur un match comme ça très
clairement favori là en fait
est une très bonne équipe d'Allemagne
mais quand même bien cran en dessous
bien en dessous à Bruges alors ça c'est
toujours intéressant pas mal le premier
je pense brut pour la deuxième équipe
donc Bruges ne peut pas jouer Manchester
City qui vient de tirer ni le FC Porto
on va voir quelle équipe Bruges
va-t-elle rencontrer
Bruges qui a produit du du très beau jeu
c'était l'autre l'autre équipe
surprenante je cite Naples tout à
l'heure mais Bruges tu es vraiment
l'attendait pas du tout et il faisait
figure de 4e
clairement sur le papier maintenant si
il tombe sur le Bayern de Munich ils
peuvent quand même d'un seul coup
toucher leur limite
et bien ce sera le Benfica Bruges
Benfica donc là ça ouvre déjà une équipe
en quart de finale même si encore une
fois je c'est ce que je disais
attention on a vu contre le PSG que
c'était pas ça je vais bien c'était ça
jouait bien que c'était solide que
c'était jeune mais là Benfica favori
bien sûr mais bon mais mais jouable je
jouable des deux côtés et on aura une
équipe un peu moins cador dans les
quarts de finale aussi c'est ça donc il
y aura déjà une boule à tirer sur
l'autre épouvantail le Liverpool FC qui
ne peut pas jouer ni contre Tottenham ni
contre Chelsea ni contre la police ce
sera Porto Bayern Munich ou Real Madrid
soit un très gros soit la bonne pioche
ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure sur les
équipes pour l'instant Liverpool fait
pas figure enfin impressionne pas depuis
le début de la saison mais décidément de
février ça peut il y a du potentiel
Madrid Liverpool Real Madrid dès les 8e
de finale je pense qu'on a notre gros
choc a priori en tout cas le premier
peut-être qu'on a droit à notre voilà
mais là on a déjà une très très belle
affiche pour une fois
pas forcément bien servi par le tirage
au sort du coup voilà donc
mais en groupe ils avaient ils avaient
ils avaient quand même eu un groupe très
abordable donc
suivant équipe le Milan AC le Milan AC
l'équipe italienne qui revient sur le
devant la scène qui a été championne
italienne et qui fait plutôt une bonne
saison avec d'ailleurs à Olivier Giroud
assez recrute à marquer un petit bijou
ce weekend c'était magnifique c'était
magnifique ça me paraît compliqué pour
dire des choses pas l'emmener au 4 alors
surtout après quelque chose comme ça
donc le Milan AC on va voir contre qui
va tomber le j'aimerais bien voir tomber
le bail en 2000 quand même un moment
donné ce serait quand même sympa il
reste plus que il reste plus beaucoup ce
sera peut-être
là aussi ça va être assez ouvert
finalement qu'est-ce qu'il y a un favori
dans ce dans ce match
pas vrai de mon point de vue pas
vraiment je trouve que 1000 ans pour
l'instant et peut-être un peu favori
parce que Tottenham réalise un début de
saison très spécial ou franchement dans
le jeu c'est c'est assez médiocre mais
ils sont quatrième de première ligne il
gagne ils ont un mental à toute épreuve
donc pas une équipe simple lentracte
Francfort donc ça ça peut pas être le
Bayer pas le Bayern non plus mais il y a
déjà deux clubs allemands qui sont
tombés donc on est sur une chance sur
trois alors je n'ai plus les
probabilités exactes par contrat mais
donc là ce sera pour Porto Napoli et la
troisième équipe que je n'ai pas vu ici
Chelsea voilà Porto Napoli Chelsea
Porto sort là
on aurait deux affiches assez
entre Bruges Benfica et Francfort il
fait Francfort Porto ça nous ferait deux
affiches assez
vous parliez tout à l'heure de l'indice
pour les clubs portugais avec les clubs
portugais pourraient non ce sera Napoli
Napoli contre Francfort donc Napoli va
pouvoir continuer à avoir un tirage
plutôt facile parce que Francfort donc
ils ont remporté la Ligue Europa c'est
comme ça qu'ils sont qualifiés pour la
Ligue des Champions et ils ont pas non
plus montré des choses absolument
fabuleuses si si Naples arrivent à
conserver le niveau qu'ils ont montré
sur sur ce premier tiers de saison
Naples est clairement favori
effectivement avec colomanie Olivia qui
nous demande où sont les Marseillais ben
ils ne sont pas qualifiés effectivement
ils ne sont pas non plus en Ligue Europa
sont devant leur télévision
Dortmund ce ne sera pas non plus pour
parler de Munich donc on est Dortmund ce
sera pour Porto ou Chelsea
dans les 2e de groupe
mais donc Dortmund pour Chelsea ou Porto
si Chelsea pouvait tomber ça arrangerait
quand même pas mal les Parisiens je
pense on va voir ce qui va arriver
et ce sera donc Chelsea effectivement
Dortmund Chelsea et ben écoutez je pense
que on est dans le scénario du soit le
meilleur tirage pour le Paris
Saint-Germain soit le pire ah bah
écoutez Porto Porto ou Bayern sachant
que dans les 2e de groupe alors je n'ai
plus la liste sous les yeux à l'Inter et
il y a l'Inter qui reste il y a une
terre qui reste donc
était dans le groupe du Bayern inter ne
peut pas jouer le Bayern donc c'est donc
effectivement donc c'est cadeau interne
vont chercher le pire tirage on l'a
est-ce que est-ce qu'on a beaucoup de
chance côté parisien
le Bayern selon moi par favori mais le
PSG
le PSG a montré sur ces sur ses propres
mémoires que avec avec sa triplette avec
un messie retrouvé il était capable de
tout que même certains matchs où ça joue
pas bien il y a des fulgurances devant
qui qui les sauvent ça va être un match
très ouvert à priori très offensif donc
en tout cas ils vont être face à une
équipe qui joue donc ça c'est c'est
quelque chose qui vont qui est plutôt
appréciable donc maintenant
dans le Bayern c'est costaud puis c'est
une équipe dont on sait qu'elle va pas
qu'elle va pas faiblir comme je vous le
disais c'est ils ont ils ont un nombre
de joueurs qui est capable de de briller
dans tout dans tous les côtés donc bon
il y a beaucoup de Français c'est bien
ça
voilà le PSG va retrouver chaud pour
Moting
donc
non non ça va être ça va être une
confrontation très intéressante mais
mais pour moi c'est le pire des tirages
mais qui est qui est le favori dans ce
dans ce match là moi je dirais
légèrement le Bayern sur ce sur ce qu'on
a vu sur ce sur ce début de saison même
si ils ont connu quelques trous il y a
eu quelques résultats un peu étonnants
Bundesliga ils ont déjà concédé je crois
4 matchs nuls leur entraîneur a failli
faire virer donc il y a il y a pas il y
a pas une sérénité absolue parce que
normalement quand même les bandes aussi
donc ils ont plus au numéro 9 qui
bonifiait des fois leur jeu mais
puis derrière c'est pas toujours
l'assurance touriste donc heureusement
qu'ils ont manuel Nuer après ils ont pas
eu gorets de SCAP pendant quasiment tous
les buts de saison et quand même un pion
majeur de leur entre jeux on voit que ça
Bitzer commence à prendre un peu ses
aises après une première saison assez
assez délicate
ça va être ça va être ça va être
intéressant faut voir aussi le petit
jeune gravenberge comment le comment il
continue à progresser il est plutôt il
est plutôt bon de plus depuis le début
de saison mais
c'est un peu mon inquiétude en fait j'ai
un peu peur que le Bayern soit encore
plus fort dans trois mois en fait donc
après la Coupe du monde ils peuvent
mieux revenir tout s'articulent bien
alors que le PSG pas vraiment c'est pas
forcément ce qui va se passer le PSG
voilà ça peut peu subir un contrecoup
sur la Coupe du monde peut-être plus
important que le Bayern de Munich a
priori
effectivement donc le PSG Bayern de
Munich vous l'avez vu on l'a pas parlé
du coup du choc du choc du match entre
Inter de Milan et FC Porto là clairement
l'Inter de Milan qui a terminé deuxième
un deuxième groupe qui se retrouve
contre un premier et qui a priori quand
même assez favoris oui Nintendo
l'expérience il y a un peu de tout ils
sont ils ont quand même réussi à finir
devant le Barça donc ouais oui je pense
que
media il y aura des équipes
quand on regarde là c'est vrai que en
quart de finale des tu auras Bruges ou
Benfica qui aura Francfort ou Naples
alors effectivement le Naples donc on a
vu là mais ils seront très dangereux
mais c'était pas forcément on les on les
imaginait pas forcément là
inter ou Porto
on va non non ça va être il y a deux
deux très très belles affiches quand
même un Liverpool - Real de Madrid et
PSG - Bayern de Munich je pense que
c'est les deux plus gros du chapeau 1 et
les deux plus gros du chapeau de sur le
papier effectivement et PSG Bayern de
Munich en Ligue des Champions la
dernière fois ça a quand même souris au
PSG si je me trompe pas ouais mais bon
il y en a aussi sur le souvenir d'une
finale paire de nous effectivement ça ça
pas toujours ça pas toujours souri donc
donc au niveau de l'historique je suis
pas sûr que l'historique des
confrontations soit en faveur du
j'essaie de retrouver l'année mais je ne
l'ai plus en tête en tout cas Bernard
Dominique effectivement alors j'ai
repris juste leur groupe de 0 contre une
terre de Milan 2-0 contre le FC
Barcelone 5-0 contre le victoire
contre le Barça 2-0 contre 2000 ans
bavures ça va assez vite et puis bon
mais je disais qu'ils étaient pas très
solide en défense mais ils en ont pas
pris tant que ça
non non c'est une équipe c'est c'est
je crois qu'ils sont à combien 40 41
buts marqués en monnaie Lega bon après
on dirait la Bundesliga on a on a
l'habitude de de voir des défenses un
petit peu permissive mais ça va être ça
va être un match très compliqué il faut
espérer que la Coupe du monde
comment dire n'offre pas de mauvaises
surprises
aux Parisiens qui reviennent pas parce
que je trouve que Messi quand même le
Messie qu'on a là et quand même pour moi
aujourd'hui le dépositaire du jeu du PSG
quand Messi dans un bon jour
généralement tout le monde brille à côté
parce qu'il a cette capacité à voilà à
faire jouer les autres
il faudrait pas que Messi revienne
blesser
de du Qatar effectivement je regardais
juste Bayern de Munich qui vient de
passer deuxième qui vient de passer
premier du classement que puisque il
n'est pas premier puisque là c'était
l'union de berline une petite surprise
qui a pris une raclée ce week-end donc
qui redescendu un peu sur terre mais le
Bayern a pas été rayonnant comme à son
habitude en Bundesliga jusqu'à présent
donc ce qui montre que sur certains
matchs ils sont ils sont prenables c'est
pas c'est pas un rouleau compresseur
absolu et on peut pas dire que le pays
que le Bayern de Munich est un immense
favori ça serait mes estimés surtout que
le le Paris Saint-Germain montré quand
même de belles choses par séquence sur
ce sur ce début de saison et que
défensivement va falloir qu'il soit plus
solide qu'ils n'ont été parce que pour
l'instant le PSG en défense et il y a
des matchs où je les trouve très bons et
puis il y a des matchs récemment contre
trois on se dit que si trois arrivent à
transpercer la défense du PSG de cette
manière de Munich ça va être si Mama
Baldé pose des problèmes au PSG ça va
être quoi quand ils auront saigné à
brioche
et le petit musciala aussi qui est très
bon non non c'est et puis c'est une
équipe assez dur à défendre parce que ça
il change ça permet de beaucoup ça
permet d'énormément on sait jamais
vraiment qui est numéro 9 ça joue au
vite
bon il y a toujours Thomas simuler qui
est le joueur qui ne vieillit pas
visiblement qui reste toujours là et qui
marque débute on envoie beaucoup qui
sont en train de faiblir on a vu Cavani
qui est parti Louis Suarez tout ça enfin
on voit des on les voit plus en Ligue
des Champions Thomas est toujours là et
toujours toujours performant alors ça
c'était toujours pareil on le voit jouer
on se dit oui pas vraiment de qualité ce
gars là
qu'on voit ce qu'il apporte au Bayern de
Munich on se dit ah oui d'accord donc il
y a des c'est quand même assez
impressionnant et du coup faut voir
effectivement le PSG comment les trois
devant arrivent à collaborer pendant les
huitièmes de finale parce que on se
rappelle que l'an dernier on avait une
équipe qui devait gagner la Ligue des
Champions et on s'est fait sortir en 8e
de finale c'était pas le mais si de ce
premier trimestre et pas le Messie qui
avait face aux face au Real à ce
moment-là il est aujourd'hui dans un
état de forme beaucoup
nettement meilleur qu'avant physiquement
il est beaucoup plus au point on saura
jamais vraiment à quel point le covid
l'affecté à un moment donné à perturber
aussi le fait qu'il n'y ait pas eu de
préparation d'avance saison l'adaptation
à Paris même y compris pour sa famille
enfin il y avait plein de choses l'année
dernière qui pouvaient expliquer ça là
on a pas retrouvé le le grand Messie de
du Barça on a on a un messie vraiment
vraiment très bon et surtout très juste
dans ces orientations de jeu moi
j'apprécie autant autant j'avais été
très très déçu parce qu'il avait montré
la saison dernière y compris dans l'état
d'esprit autant là je suis vraiment
totalement séduit effectivement un petit
pronostic sur les affiches peut-être
avant de avant de se quitter pendant un
petit moment puisque après on fera le
tiroir de de la Ligue Europa les psy je
Manchester City City Club de Bruges
contre Benfica Benfica Liverpool Real
Madrid le premier gros choc là c'est
toujours compliqué alors aujourd'hui je
dirais le Real mais mais je crois que le
Liverpool je vois des choses dans leur
jeu qui me laisse sa pensée que on voit
que Darwin Nunes commence à être de de
mieux en mieux il avait bien débuté la
saison après il a eu un coup de moins
allez je vais je vais mettre une petite
pièce sur le Liverpool sur la surprise
Liverpool surprise Milan AC - Tottenham
là je vais dire je suis comme dire
Tottenham je pense
malgré leur espèce de poule et le fait
que bon c'est moi je suis un grand grand
fan de minson donc c'est un petit
pronostic du cœur allez petit frère
aussi du cœur pour celui-là Francfort
Naples
Dortmund Chelsea ah celui-là aussi là
c'est intéressant est-ce que est-ce que
est-ce que Chelsea est assez solide pour
battre Dortmund ça va être vrai Dortmund
c'est
Dortmund ce qu'il a ils ont ils ont pas
remplacé à lande c'est quand même le
grand problème puisque avec ce qui s'est
malheureusement passé pour alerte et
puis ils ont pris anthony Modeste qui
leur fait du bien Bundesliga mais qui en
Ligue des Champions n'importe
strictement rien donc je pense qu'il a
le niveau Bundesliga il a pas le niveau
Ligue des Champions
Chelsea a quand même l'expérience il y a
beaucoup moi je dirais Chelsea quand
même je pense mais
51 49 quoi 50 à 49 inter des millions de
FC Porto c'est un peu plus
et PSG Bayern donc voilà je dirais la
raison du rail Bayern mais mais j'ai
envie que le PSG avec loin donc Paris
Saint-Germain allez Paris Saint-Germain
merci Cédric pour ces petits pronostics
et on se retrouve d'ici une petite
demi-heure pour vous faire vivre le
tirage au sort de la Ligue Europa et là
pour le coup il y aura pas un mais trois
clubs français à suivre et il y aura
quelques beaux cadors notamment la
Juventus et le FC Barcelone tout à fait
ouais ça peut on peut avoir encore de
très belles affiches et autant Ligue des
Champions j'espérais un tirage plus
clément pour le PSG autant en Ligue
Europa autant prendre des gros autant
prendre surtout pour Nantes je pense
qu'on en parlera tout à l'heure mais
autant prendre un gros quoi
effectivement on en parlera dans une
petite demi-heure et on vous dit à
bientôt sur Figaro live
rebonjour on est de retour pour le
tirage au sort de la Ligue Europa vous
l'avez vu le Bayern de Munich jouera
contre le Paris Saint-Germain gros
tirage pour le Paris Saint-Germain et on
va voir ce qui va attendre maintenant
les clubs français engagés en Europa
League puisque il y a les barrages de
l'Europa League je suis toujours Cédric
rebonjour re-bonjour Vincent on va
parler avec vous maintenant de la
deuxième Coupe d'Europe la C3 avec pas
moins de 3 clubs engagés côté français
Rennes Nantes et Monaco oui et puis avec
avec des adversaires potentiels qui
sentent bon la Ligue des Champions
presque un pour on a longtemps et
souvent décrié cette compétition là
franchement il y a un petit plateau fort
sympathique alors ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que là pour l'instant ce n'est pas
le territoire de 8e c'est le territoire
des 16e c'est à dire que il y a eu des
phases de groupe le premier groupe
allait directement en huitième de finale
et le deuxième jouer un barrage en fait
contre le troisième de Ligue des
Champions exactement et donc ce qui me
fait dire que déjà d'un point de vue
personnel j'estime que quel que soit le
tirage au sort Rennes est déjà perdant
rien n'est déjà perdu puisque sur ce
qu'ils ont montré dans la phase de
groupe ils auraient dû finir premier là
ils devraient être tranquillement devant
leur télé ou même pas en avoir rien à
faire de ce tirage au sort et là il se
retrouve avec la perspective peut-être
de tomber sur Barcelone ou la Juventus
vraiment ils ont devancé par Fenerbahçe
une équipe qu'ils ont largement dominé à
un moment donné dans la phase de groupe
non non Rennes Rennes peut avoir des
regrets de d'être concernés aujourd'hui
du côté de Nantes peut-être Nantes qui a
fait une phase de poule qui s'est
qualifié un peu à l'arracher bah alors
non c'est tout l'inverse non tu penses
que là aujourd'hui
il faut pas il faut pas se leurrer
l'idéal pour non c'est le plus gros
possible
sans doute mourir de leur belle-morts
façon en offrant une magnifique affiche
à la Beaujoire donc pour Nantes ça
serait mieux d'avoir Barcelone ou la
Juventus que que Salzbourg redonesque ça
c'est ça c'est une certitude
oui effectivement damso damso qui nous
dit Nantes Barça ce serait génial Monaco
contre Barcelone et après il y a Monaco
aussi Monaco aussi ils auraient pu jouer
le la première place oui parce que bon
faire un varrow bon c'est certes
champion hongrois mais bon c'est pas une
référence
à partir de là mais sur ce qu'ils ont
ils sont irréguliers Monaco pulliver la
saison donc contrairement à Rennes qui
vraiment a montré par un certain moment
ça supériorité dans ce groupe et un peu
craqué sur certaines formats ou même
gagner des matchs enfin ça a été assez
fallait rester jusqu'au bout pour Rennes
ça c'était certain Monaco aujourd'hui
c'est pas illogique qui soit là c'est
amusant de voir que ils sont dans le
même chapeau que le PS Vanden qui les a
éliminé en barrage de Ligue des
Champions enfin c'était même pas le
barrage et après le PSV c'est fait
éliminé en barrage et enfin du coup on
retrouve les deux dans le dans le même
chapeau donc ils ne peuvent pas
s'affronter mais
Monaco je trouvais à sa place et ça va
être intéressant de
avoir le tirage pour Monaco et il y a
effectivement des gros noms de l'autre
côté donc postwidown mid-y land je vous
ai posé pas trop de questions sur le sur
le sur l'équipe de midi Land le club
français peuvent pas jouer midinand donc
j'ai pas réviser mes fiches en vigilance
alors que du coup par contre vous avez
beaucoup révisé sur du menu de l'achat
et peut-être plus le FC Barcelone voilà
c'est barçoit il n'y a pas besoin de
réviser plus que ça donc c'est vraiment
le je pense que c'est l'énorme équipe la
Juventus et aussi un énorme nom mais qui
semble aujourd'hui plus en difficulté
Barcelone est quand même aujourd'hui
leader de de la Liga alors certes avec
un Real de Madrid joue ce soir pour
reprendre pour reprendre sa place de
leader mais avec des chiffres
impressionnants une équipe jeune les
bandovski enfin donc c'est vraiment le
l'ogre absolu donc voilà donc ça peut
être quand même sympa de jouer et puis
on l'a peut-être pas dit mais dans la
deuxième de groupe il y a aussi des
beaux noms finalement alors qu'on ne
jouerons pas les Français mais il y a
quand même l'AS Roma et man tout à fait
on peut avoir un Manchester United FC
Barcelone en 16ème de finale enfin en
barrage de la Ligue Europa c'est oui là
c'est c'est comme ça serait quand même
assez assez amusant
sans doute pas pour les supporters des
deux clubs et puis quelque part surtout
peut-être plus pour United que pour
Barcelone c'est quand même le symbole
d'aujourd'hui de leurs difficultés et
des difficultés des redbils alors que
Barcelone ils viennent de la Ligue des
Champions ils sont fait quand même une
idée par l'Inter de Milan et par le
Bayern donc pas par n'importe qui non
plus donc le déclassement est moins
moins douloureux on va dire alors c'est
Zoltan jera qui va effectuer le tirage
au sort c'est un joueur de fullam je ne
vous poserai pas trop dit trop de
questions sur certaines du rap donc
voilà qui est l'ambassadeur de la Ligue
Europa de cette année très bien qui
effectuera le tirage au sort qui va
commencer si quelques minutes comme vous
le savez on peut pas vous montrer dites
nous un peu ce que vous attendez vous
pour les pour les clubs français
qu'est-ce que c'est quoi le bon tirage
finalement pour les clubs français alors
le bon tirage
le gros on a compris le trait là alors
le très gros c'est Barcelone et pour
Nantes ça serait parfait parce que
Nantes même face à ce qu'il y a de plus
abordable franchement ça sera pas gagné
non plus donc le plus abordable là sur
le sur le papier bon il y a forcément
donné ce que qui a qui même qui est
quand même fini 3e de ce groupe de Ligue
des Champions mais qui qui club
ukrainien qui vit donc forcément des
heures toujours difficiles et toujours
compliqué et on sait pas ce qu'il en
sera quand on sera au mois de février
donc pour donner ce que donnait ce que
malheureusement ça ça peut être un bon
tirage sur ce qu'ils ont montré depuis
le début de la saison le FC Séville est
complètement à la rue donc ils sont 17e
en Ligue 1
ils ont pas voilà il y a on attaque
c'est c'est famélique c'est une équipe
vieillissante qui a un passé très
glorieux dans la compétition qu'elle a
remporté notamment je crois 2014-2015
2016-2020 mais aujourd'hui franchement
là c'est ça tout du bon tirage
après le reste les vertus sonne a eu
aussi des difficultés en Bundesliga mais
là ce week-end ils ont battu l'Union
Berlin 5-0 et il y a quand même de très
bons joueurs notamment
ne risque d'être plus fort en février
que qu'il ne l'est aujourd'hui Sporting
Portugal bon bah ils ont une revanche à
prendre parce que ils ont fait une
campagne de Ligue des Champions plutôt
très honorable mais ils sont ratés les
deux matchs contre l'Olympique de
Marseille donc ce qui leur vaut d'être
là aujourd'hui
donc ça sera pas pas forcément simple et
puis l'Ajax c'est toujours pareil l'Ajax
c'est jeune ça serait ça joue bien au
football ça partira l'an prochain si je
vous bien habituel alors je réponds
juste à diamètre frigo effectivement
mais effectivement voilà il y avait des
questions sur pourquoi il y avait pas
les premiers groupes les premiers
groupes seront là au prochain tour ils
sont des qualifiés directement ils
pourraient ils sont tranquilles de leur
côté et c'est ce qui aurait pu arriver à
Rennes mais ce qui ne sera pas le cas on
l'a dit voilà le tirage au sort va
commencer d'ici quelques instants euh on
fait suivre ça en direct Monaco sur
Juventus pour une revanche je signe tous
les jours Monaco - Juventus était en
demi-finale de Ligue des Champions
époque Mbappe ça commence à dater un peu
en tout cas au niveau de la coupe de
performance des deux clubs ça ça semble
bien loin maintenant
ouais ça Monaco je pense Monaco on peut
espérer plutôt ça serait quand même
mieux un tirage comme du FC Séville ou
ou Salzbourg Paris pour Rennes parce que
je pense que eux ont clairement les
moyens Nantes aussi un peu éliminé
Salzbourg mais voilà je pense que je
pense que Nantes je crois que c'est
Antoine Comboire qui a dit qu'ils
étaient les nains de la compétition
alors quand on est nain bah pourquoi pas
prendre le géant voilà effectivement et
puis il faut le rappeler aussi Nantes
est-ce que la Coupe d'Europe c'est
vraiment leur
principale chose sachant que quand même
on est en Ligue 1 et 4 décembre en fin
de saison voilà donc je pense que c'est
pas leur priorité donc
vraiment même si il y a toujours la
glorieuse incertitude du sport
Nantes qui jouent le FC Barcelone et
puis voilà de une magnifique affiche la
Beaujoire si possible une belle
résistance et de beau match et puis et
puis après ce concombre sur le
championnat parce que la scène
européenne sera terminée plutôt que
d'aller
jouer contre Donetsk alors je ne sais
plus où donner ce que je joue à Domi où
jouera donnez ce qu'à domicile en
février mars c'était en Pologne c'est un
Pologne
c'est moins moins intéressant c'est mon
intéressant effectivement on peut pour
regarder des forces c'est important le
tirage au sort va commencer d'ici
quelques instants on est en train de
réexpliquer les règles de qui est là qui
n'est pas là qui peut jouer l'un contre
l'autre ça sera plus simple qu'en Ligue
des Champions puisque je crois que la
solo avec ça de ne pas rencontrer un peu
de club d'un même pays donc ça exclut un
PSV Ajax mais après ça exclut pas ouais
Rome un berline le RCZ oui effectivement
il y a pas non plus énormément de
club anglais en troisième déjà
effectivement
on nous dit Roma Barça pour la revanche
de la première remontada effectivement
et on se sent on se rappelle de cette
remontada
ouais ouais ça ça serait
moi moi j'espère Barcelone pour Nantes
mais sinon ça m'amuserait de les voir
contre Manchester United plus que pour
que face à la Roma alors on va voir le
premier la première équipe à être tiré
ça arrive tout de suite nous avons le FC
Barcelone et ben voilà on va t'avoir
assez vite qui va affronter le FC
Barcelone on l'a dit épouvanté la
compétition peut-être même le grand
favori maintenant de cette compétition
et là il faut se rappeler tous les
premiers groupes je suis en train
d'essayer de mais enfin je vois pas de
premier pour moi le Barça est favori
c'est sûr effectivement c'est la réalité
qui avait sorti United par exemple on
n'est pas non plus sur le même sur le
même niveau donc on va voir contre qui
va jouer le FC Barcelone sachant que on
l'a dit le Barcelone peut jouer contre
chaque équipe puisqu'il n'y a pas de
d'autres clubs possibles Nantes alors on
va voir on enlève la boule et on va voir
contre qui le club va jouer Manchester
United
il y avait deux gros club il tombe là
contre l'autre
ça ressemble au tirage au sort de Ligue
des Champions aussi qui nous a quand
même réservé de très très grosses
affiches alors qu'on aurait pu avoir
pas ça donc là assez ouvert voilà 16e de
finale de Ligue Europa on a un choc qui
pourrait être un quart de Ligue des
Champions c'est quand même compliqué
mais ce ça aurait été pas le niveau
actuel de de United oui c'est ça ça
paraît ça paraît compliqué par contre
vous replongez il y a juste trois quatre
ans ça aurait pu être un carot Juventus
qui est iranienne voilà bon tire les
gros au début hein comme ça aussi c'est
toujours pas un job français bon bah là
ça comme ça c'est bon pour voir on va
pas venir de l'aide qui était qui est à
la tête de la Juventus anti-star donc là
Juventus qui ne peut pas jouer contre
seulement et on va voir contre qui est
le club
va jouer cette cette équipe
Juventus Juventus qui a été dans le
groupe du PSG qui s'est fait sortir en
3e et ça il y avait pas vraiment photos
on va dire non non c'est une Juve un peu
sur le déclin qui reste solide
défensivement mais qui dans le jeu a
beaucoup de mal voilà en milieu c'est
beaucoup de jeunes
le FC Nantes le FC Nantes
c'était la Juve qu'il fallait donc ça va
faire une très belle affiche voilà il va
y avoir de la hovitch
Di Maria j'espère s'il est pas blessé et
tout qui vont venir Bonucci voilà c'est
c'est des grands noms c'est c'est quand
même ça ils ont quand même battu une
Inter de Milan là ce week-end donc faut
pas enterrer complètement la Juve ça ils
peuvent revenir assez vite parce que
dans tes favoris
oui si si
Bonucci Di Maria rabiot et puis de deux
autres sont pas là oui peut-être si leur
manque leur sept meilleur joueur c'est
peut-être possible on va voir du coup
c'est le Sporting Portugal qui vient
d'être retiré en pour ce troisième 8e 8e
3e 16e de finale on rappelle les
premiers groupes sur les filles
directement c'est un barrage donc ce
sera le FG midiland le club danois dans
lequel joue yolas le seul qui était
ancien gardien de Guingamp voilà donc ça
va confirmer un petit peu ce que j'ai ce
que j'ai lu un peu sur les sur les
réseaux sociaux à juste titre que c'est
une journée plutôt plutôt favorable pour
les pour les clubs portugais au niveau
du muscle Porto et Benfica n'ont pas été
malheureux en Ligue des Champions là je
pense que le Sporting Portugal est pas
malheureux non plus donc
[Musique]
vous en parliez tout à l'heure Vincent
du de l'indice va falloir se méfier des
clubs portugais parce que là si les
trois continents effectivement alors le
Shakhtar donetsky a retirer chaque carte
qui peut jouer contre heidhoven le Stade
Rennais l'AS Roma l'union de berline ou
laisse Monaco club français donc il
reste encore deux clubs français à jouer
contre qui va jouer le choc sur Denis
qu'on le sait chaque jour qui a quand
même pas passé loin d'une qualification
en 8e de finale oui oui ça ça joue
toujours bien donné toujours
le Real de Madrid en Ligue des Champions
phase de poule en plus donc c'est quand
même pas forcément
le Stade Rennais pour le facteur de NES
quand même ça va on va voyager du côté
de Rennes du coup voilà donc c'est
soit ils sont ils sont pas premier pour
l'instant du championnat ukrainien c'est
voilà c'est c'est c'est une équipe bon
faut toujours voir comment le elle va
passer l'hiver donc ça c'est toujours
toujours malheureusement compliqué pour
pour les clubs ukrainien et les clubs
russes avant donc sans bon tirage pour
elle vraiment l'Ajax d'Amsterdam qui a
été tiré on l'a dit l'Ajax d'Amsterdam
qui est toujours un grand club qui a
toujours des grands joueurs qui partent
l'année après qu'il soit très très bon
mais ils ont toujours
une équipe qui voilà qui bon de deuxième
de son championnat mais avec un match en
retard mais qui offensivement et et très
forte parce que elle s'appuie sur plein
de bons joueurs brobé coup douce le
retour de bergouin qui qui a pas réussi
à Tottenham et qui a l'air de bien se
relancer à l'Ajax
l'union de berline pour l'Ajax
du début de saison Bundesliga donc comme
je disais tout à l'heure ils se sont
retomber un peu sur Terre en prenant 5-0
ce week-end face à aller vers Clusaz
mais
bon ça va être un match un match assez
ouvert quand même on peut voir beaucoup
de buts sur sur cette confrontation
Bayer Leverkusen les Allemands de Bayern
Leverkusen avec new sadiaby on l'a dit
un autre chat
il y a beaucoup de beaucoup de bons
joueurs
de très bons défenseurs plus assez
jeunes ça serait pas un cadeau pour
Monaco qui nous demande où sont les
premiers d'Europa League ils ne sont pas
là ils seront là autour d'après là pour
l'instant on est au barrage c'est des
barravistes ils viendront plus tard là
pour l'instant on a les deuxièmes de
groupes et les 3e de Ligue des Champions
que le Bayer Leverkusen alors j'ai une
fois de plus et bah c'est l'AS Monaco
pour le Bayern on aura un gros
une belle affiche
voilà pour l'instant donc le Bayern
Leverkusen doit être 13 ou 14e de
Bundesliga mais euh
mais il se remettent bien dans le sens
de la marche ça sera pas ça sera pas une
confrontation
simple du tout pour
pour Monaco donc
voilà je pense que Rennes est favori
Nantes ne l'est évidemment pas et Monaco
Bayern Leverkusen c'est du peut-être du
55 ans et c'est Kevin volante qui va
retrouver ses anciens
compagnons
nouveau club privé c'est le cvfc il
reste plus que trois clubs à être tiré
maintenant c'est VFC
alors il faut il faut retrouver le hop
on va prendre
la liste sous les yeux bah c'est le PS
veille de Van qui vient de sortir et
donc il va nous rester un AS Roma contre
un Salzburg un salzburgroma en dernier
match
Séville PSV eidoven Salzbourg Roma ça
nous fait quand même ça nous fait quand
même de belles affiches c'est vifc
Heiden est-ce que est-ce que heidoven
est quand même favori
pour l'instant oui très clairement là
vraiment Séville Séville j'ai regardé un
petit peu les statistiques en attaque
pour l'instant il y a mire qui a marqué
un but au niveau de leurs avançons dans
le Berg zero elle ne serie 0
c'est-à-dire que donc ils ont au niveau
du secteur offensif des numéros 9 ils
ont un but marqué depuis le début de la
Liga donc c'est pas et puis c'est
vieillissant enfin je veux dire Gomez
Papou Gomez il a 34 ans et
malheureusement il commence à les faire
à kitch c'est pareil réseau snavas 36
Isco qui est venu qui après avoir fait
du bon de touche Real de Madrid pendant
je ne sais combien de saisons a voulu se
relancer et puis finalement ils se
relance de rien du tout donc non non
pour l'instant le PSV est grandement
favori à voir si voilà on février le FC
Séville on retrouve une meilleure
carburation mais là
c'était le bon pour moi c'était l'équipe
à prendre alors vous n'hésitez pas sur
le live va nous dire dans les
commentaires ce que vous pensez de se
tirage au sort des équipes françaises je
sais qu'il y avait quelques supporters
qui étaient là AS Rome Red Bull
Salzbourg est-ce que l'AS Rome est
favorite
oui je pense quand même même si
Salzbourg c'est un petit peu c'est
devenu aujourd'hui un petit peu comme
l'Ajax c'est aussi une équipe qui forme
des jeunes qui délaisse partir dès 14
ans à peu près c'est à peine plus à
peine plus ils ont eu
en Ligue des Champions je pense que
peut-être que le jeûne Cesco là le le
Slovène de 19 ans a peut-être mis selon
moi l'un des plus beaux buts si c'est le
plus beau but de la phase de groupe
il y a aucun fort il y a des jeunes
français qu'on connaît pas du tout en
France mais ils ont un milieu de terrain
qui a 19 ans le cas Gourna a donné qui
est plutôt très bon
donc ça va être une équipe il y aura
rien à perdre AS Rome et favorite parce
que parce que plus expérimenté et tout
avec en plus un coach emblématique José
Mourinho donc mais
attention attention Fenac qui nous dit
reine se met bien Nantes peut avoir à
quoi jouer aussi on a dit quand même
pour Nantes ça va être très compliqué
mais par contre c'est quand même assez
enfin au moins la fête soit belle
voiture exactement mais la Juve il faut
faire attention parce que certes on a vu
en Ligue des Champions qu'elle avait pu
trop le niveau mais enfin le PSG c'est
pas Nantes ou non c'est pas le PSG donc
et puis en Série A pour l'instant la
Juve a si je me trompe pas la meilleure
défense donc ça reste du costaud ça
reste du solide beaucoup d'expérience
ils ont quand même même s'il fait un
début de saison un peu moyen c'est
blawich quand même qui reste un super
attaquant
Militch que que maintenant la Ligue 1
connaît bien
vraiment l'inconnu c'est parce que si
les mariés retrouve un peu de gens mais
il n'est pas blessé tous les tous les
quatre matins il peut vraiment bonifier
le jeu de la Juve et là ça peut vraiment
vraiment devenir compliqué pour Nantes
ça peut effectivement être très très
compliqué on va reprendre ces affiches
un peu comme tout à l'heure FC Barcelone
Manchester United qui c'est qui peut
l'emporter sur ce match comme la FC
Barcelone Barcelone parce que voilà de
leur début de saison est quand même
certes certains Ligues des Champions ils
ont pas vraiment existé ils ont été très
décevants mais en Liga ils sont quand
même plutôt bons ils ont ils ont
pléthore de joueurs dont certains sont
un peu décevants pour l'instant raffinia
a pas enfin vraiment convaincu mais les
vents aussi on en parle pas trop ce
qu'on parle toujours d'un autre mais en
Liga c'est 13 buts déjà donc 13 buts
encore en 13 matchs donc il a pas voilà
il a pas eu de problème d'adaptation
puis United alors de temps en temps
United ils ont sorti des bons matchs en
championnat là en première ligne mais
ils sont capables d'être catastrophique
comme ce weekend donc
[Musique]
Monaco
voilà les vertus de Monaco justement
est-ce que Monaco pour moi c'est
vraiment du 55 ans celui-là j'ai
vraiment du mal alors bon je vais dire
Monaco pour parce que je préfère voir
les clubs français aller loin mais pour
moi c'est vraiment du 55 ans
s'évier c'est contre psvideoven et
Salzbourg Roma priori Rome a priori Rome
mais attention avoir comment revient à
un certain polo 10 balles là aussi si ça
recommence un peu vapeur au football
c'est ça ouais ils ont des mes
défensivement c'est que c'est quand même
assez solide non c'est c'est la Roma
avec Mancini derrière avec Ibanez avec
Smalling c'est
je pense que ça ça risque de poser des
problèmes à Salzbourg quand même final
qui nous dit Monaco à quoi jouer bah ils
ont plus qu'un coup à jouer
effectivement là c'est vraiment enfin
après Monaco peut se montrer très
décevons aussi comme il peut se montrer
très fort ça c'est régulier pour
l'instant aussi pour l'instant le début
de saison euh voilà quand ils ont fait
match nul contre le Paris-Saint-Germain
qui avait vraiment bousculé on s'est dit
ça y est peut-être leur saison on
démarre et puis finalement derrière
c'est ça reste en dents de scie à
l'image de pas mal de leurs joueurs que
ça soit ben yeder volante qui alterne
triplé doublé et puis ensuite des matchs
pas bons bon il y a la déception pour
l'instant Minamino qui qui n'apporte
strictement rien et qui ressemble à un
accident industriel qui a coûté je crois
dans les 17 18 millions d'euros mais
Monaco enfin c'est pas un ogre le Bayern
des vertus jaune là donc était très
fébrile en face de poule et aussi et
peut-être surtout en en Bundesliga je
venais de vérifier justement 14e de
Bundesliga 12 points 3 victoires 3 nuls
cette défaite oUI NON NON pour le Bayern
mais ils viennent de mettre 5-0 à
l'Union et sur le papier il y a quand
même des joueurs qui voilà que ça soit
Moussa Diabi Patrick chic des mirails il
y a des il y a des bons joueurs il y a
des bons joueurs de ballons je pense que
on verra au moment de février je pense
que quand Monaco jouera le Bayern
Leverkusen je pense que les vertus ne
sera plus le 14e mais probablement
8e 7 ou 8e et bon ça reste rajables
parce que le 7e ou 8e de Bundesliga
c'est pas c'est pas inattenable mais je
pense pas qu'ils seront 14e dans trois
mois avec chaabi Alonso comme comment
traineur
Rome a un coup à jouer merci beaucoup
Cédric merci à vous merci à vous d'avoir
suivi ce tirage au sort on vous laisse
vous pouvez retrouver tous les articles
bien sûr sur le site du Figaro toutes
les analyses sur le site du Figaro et
moi je vous dis à bientôt pour de
nouveaux live sur Figaro live